now why have i spent all this time sort
of introducing this idea
well what it means is it's kind of my my
stepping stone
into my formal proof of euler's formula
um euler's formula you might recall it
starts off with
this expression here on the left hand
side e to the power of i
x so we've got the exponential base here
we've got some unknown x it's a variable
and then we have the imaginary unit i
squared negative 1
up here in the index as well now you may
remember
the informal result that we got for the
right-hand side of euler's formula
but i want to kind of because we're
trying to do a formal proof of this
right and do this rigorously
i want you to imagine maybe this doesn't
take imagination because you've
forgotten
but i want you to imagine how would we
find out the value of this thing if we
did not know
what it was if you didn't know what the
right-hand side was supposed to be equal
to
how would you determine its value right
now what we're going to do is we're
going to say since the field of complex
numbers
is algebraically closed if you start
with complex numbers and you put them
together no matter what you do plus
minus times divide
exponential like all those kinds of
things no matter what you do you'll stay
within the field of complex numbers
what i can say is even though i don't
know what e to the ix
is it should be a complex number of some
form right of some variety now
we've got a couple of different ways to
write complex numbers at this
point right we could write it uh in in
rectangular form
um or we could write it in um what we
would call mod arg or
polar form right using these
trigonometric equations so
um because i already know where i'm
headed and i'm going to try and do this
as efficiently as possible
even it's going to take a while right
i'm not going to use rectangular form it
ends up being i was going to say less
useful but i'm also going to say it's
just just harder to get there
and this form here um the polar form the
mod arc form is going to be much more
useful to me
okay so this thing here i don't know
what it's going to be equal to
but i know it's going to be some complex
number okay
so i'm going to use this polar form but
what i am going to do
in addition to just say i'm going to use
this form i'm not going to write it in
exactly this way because
this seems to suggest that i know what
the r and the theta are
i'm going to say it's going to be some
complex number of unknown form
with some modulus i'm going to use the
letter
m and there's going to be some other
argument
so it's going to be cos of instead of
using theta i'm going to use the letter
t plus i whoopsie daisy
sine t okay
now um what are we saying here right
we've got this this weirdo expression on
the left hand side
um but you're putting complex numbers
into it and you are expecting to get
complex numbers
out and every complex number that we can
think of anywhere on the complex plane
can be expressed in this form so for
some particular modulus
and for some particular argument now the
only catch is and the thing that's
tricky about this right
is that i'm going to treat i mean is a
number 2.718 etc
i is a number the square root of
negative 1. these guys are well defined
but x is a variable um i'm going to
treat x as something that can change
value
now if this thing can change value that
means that the complex number you get at
the end can also
change value which means that let's see
if we can use some
some highlighting over here i'll change
this over to purple so i don't have to
confused oh pink will do i'm going to
say this
this modulus here right when i say
m i don't just mean a number i mean
m as a function of x
if x can change is it easy if x can
change if it's variable
then the modulus of like if this complex
number can change so therefore its
modulus should be able to change as well
so m is a shorthand for m as a function
of x
and it's going to be the same deal for t
because if i change what this value is
then i'm going to change the complex
number that i get over the right hand
side so the argument will change as well
so when you see me writing t what i
actually mean
is t as a function of x
so these guys here are shorthand for
t of x okay so i guess
a long way to write it is to say
if i've got e to the ix it equals
m of x multiplied by
cos of i'm going to use a curly brace
here because i've got so many brackets
flying around okay
this is going to be t of x plus
i sine of t
of x okay so
i know this looks like a bit of a mess
but uh this is this is how we're going
to have to deal with it because it's a
complex
a complicated idea so we need to use
some complicated tools to do it
all right so this is what i've set up
i've got this thing and i'm trying to
find out this will be my goal right
what is my my function at the front here
the modulus will change but how will it
change
and then what will be my functions in
here the argument will change but how
will it change this will be the question
okay
so um this may seem a bit familiar to
the informal proof you might remember
it kind of was built on this idea right
that you had a
real part and you had an imaginary part
but because they changed i called them a
x and b of x well this time i'm using
the polar form i'm kind of going
straight there
but i'm recognizing the fact that i
don't know what the modulus will be and
i don't know what the
arguments will be so i'm going to have
to sort out like what are those right
now i'm going to employ the same tool
that i used before
with my informal proof with the
rectangular form and that is calculus
right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take
this awkward line i'm going to take the
left hand side and right hand side i'm
going to differentiate
both of them so let's have a go with
that um the derivative
of uh e to the ix equals the derivative
of and then i have this thing this
entire
thing here so i'm going to duplicate
that
and i've run out of different kinds of
brackets i'm going to use some really
big
square ones okay so what have i got here
well on the left hand side let's deal
with that because it's a bit easier
first
this is an exponential right now you've
already looked at these before so
the derivative of this this is chain
rule again is going to be the derivative
of the inside which in this case
the derivative of ix is just i and then
the derivative of the outside is e to
the power of something so the derivative
of that is just e to the power of
something the same something by the way
so that's e to the i x so i've dealt
with the left hand side that's good
now what's going on the right hand side
well this this is a mess
so we are going to have to deal with it
fairly carefully and
slowly the first thing is i noticed that
i have a product
here inside here so i've got this guy
and then i've got this guy here
right so i'm going to call this my
u and i'm going to call this my v
now when i use the product rule i'm
going to have to say
the derivative will be v u dash plus u v
dash but i need to know
what each of those things are and that's
as you can see a little bit messy
because my my v in this case um this
this is a mess it's gonna there's like
sort of um
a really deep rabbit hole here right
let's functions within functions within
functions so we're gonna have to do this
nice and slow let's take our time
through it so uh
first let's do with u right so u is just
equal to
m of x so therefore u dash
i would just write that as m i'm
actually going to use um i'm going to
switch over to
the leibniz notation here so i'm going
to go dm
on dx i actually i try to avoid my dash
notation if i can especially when it's
mixing with other things because it's so
easy to confuse with powers right
that's that is definitely a dash and not
a one uh now what do we have next well
i'm defining
v as uh this mess here right
so i'm gonna write that as i'm just
gonna duplicate it over here
am i gonna have enough space i have a
feeling i'm gonna have to make it
smaller
that'll just fit all right so there's my
i'll move this out of the way
there's my v so what is v dash well
you again have a complicated mess in
here right so let's just zoom in over
here and see what's going on
um i need to differentiate all of these
different pieces here but there's
several things
happening so let's just look at this
first bit here because
of t of x so this is chain rule i said
we were going to use this we've already
used it once
um here comes the second time right so
because of a function
you do the inside and then you do the
outside well in this case the inside is
t of x so therefore its derivative the
inside derivative i'm going to switch
over to live bits now right is dt
on dx okay oh sorry by the way i should
have said if you've not been introduced
to the history of this right
um calculus differential calculus when
it was first being devised
generally we agree now we understand
through the lens of of
hindsight and history that isaac newton
and a guy named got through leibniz they
kind of
invented calculus at the same time and
um the the main notation that we use
these days is leibniz's notation which
is um
you know this d y or dx or dt on dx or
whatever you like right
so there is um the inside derivative now
let's do the outside
this is cos cos differentiates as i said
i'm just going to take this as a result
you can go and have a look
at the videos if you want to see how to
prove this result the derivative of cos
is
negative sine so let's just write that
like so negative
sine and i don't need to differentiate
this thing anymore so i'm going to write
that as t
like so okay actually you know what i
don't need those big square brackets
let's just use regular ones
okay there's the first part there but
now i need to deal with this part as
well
so i'm going to deal with the derivative
of the inside and the outside
the derivative of the inside well it's t
of x is the inside function again
so i'm going to get dt on dx
then what happens on the inside well
i've got
an i which is just a constant so it's
going to hang out the front there
i and then sine of of of something is
going to become cos of something so i
end up with
cos of t
okay so what if what have we just done
um you've got uh
two uses of the chain rule within our
use of the product rule okay
so yes that is a bit messy um we could
tidy up a teeny tiny bit um i'll go
minus uh what should i write first i'll
go minus of
sine t dt on dx
plus i cos t
dt on dx all right at last
we've got v dash so now i'm going to be
doing my product rule i've got my u my u
dash my v
my v dash there's a lot there but
thankfully this will
like this is probably about the worst
point once i start substituting all this
in
it will start to collapse together from
there all right
so v u dash u v dash here we go
v is just going to be uh cos of i
i'm gonna stop writing t of x like i did
over here because i did it just to
remind me it's a function when i'm
differentiating
but i've done all my different journey
now so it's going to be
cos of t plus i
sine of t there's v
what's u dash well here is here's u dash
over here so i'm going to write that as
d m on dx
take a breath um plus let's see i think
i'm going to
i'm drastically running out of space
here but i'll do my best i'll write this
on the um
i'm going to move this down and i'm
going to use
that space a bit later on so there's my
v u dash
here comes u v dash so it's just
m that's u and then the v dash was that
very long
awkward theme that i wrote down here
this is my v dash right so what do we
got here um i've got
minus sine t dt
on dx plus i
cos t dt
on dx